when I started in my job I had the
pleasure of sitting next to James I used
to put my phone and press record and
then when I went home at night I used to
listen to it pause listen you know I
think the most powerful question you can
say in recruitment is why
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host heisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Sophie Niven
from 2B Talent Solutions we're coming up
to the the three year Milestone Mark so
a nice opportunity to reflect first year
135 second year 175 and then you're
hoping to get 180 185 Sophie's energy is
infectious we break down her cold call
openers what's working for her what
isn't and how she's gone about building
markets from scratch in geographies
where she doesn't speak the first
language over the last six to eight
months she's been building a name for
herself in the French Market she's done
the UK Market she's done the German
Market there's so many learnings in here
for any of you who are building a career
in recruitment how to go about building
a brand a reputation and most of all how
to cultivate a positive mental attitude
I'm so excited for all of you to listen
to this conversation with Sophie you
feel like you've had like a good like
fun Foundation to be a good communicator
yeah I overtalk and I think that should
have set me up to how to enjoy Sophie
welcome to the podcast thank you so much
for having me it's an honor thank you
for making the trip yeah I appreciate it
like I said always enjoy sitting down
with Northerners I'm not gonna lie my
mum is from
well from Oldham grew up in older my
grandparents are there so I I have yeah
I love Manchester my mom's from Oldham
what about it's near sure sure yeah yeah
so yeah always grew up with my mum
saying people were just so much more
nicer up north which I wholeheartedly
agree with yeah when my mum speaks to
her mum she changes her accent from
being like quite Posh in Manchester like
mine to like she has mum
hello mom she changes her voice when she
thinks so so appreciate you making a
trip down uh I guess for everyone
listening let's let's give them some
immediate context on where you are on
your recruitment Journey so your free is
in nearly nearly just shy when's three
years very soon okay yeah when's very
soon I reckon this week oh really okay
cool so we're like yeah we're we're
coming up to the the free immasto Mark
so a nice opportunity to reflect on
you know the things that have been hard
what you've got better at so the
highlight reel you let me know if any of
this is wrong okay yeah first year 175
yep
second year no first year 130. oh sorry
second year 170. sorry sorry okay as
much I'd love to have done sorry first
year 135 second year 175 and then
you're hoping to get 180 185. we're
we're getting closely 185 and I'm with
my director James we're like right let's
get the 200. let's nip it in we've got
less than six months left yeah let's
do it let's let's do it we swear
on this podcast best month today 50 G's
50g so far might be changing but we'll
see okay come on and then you've always
done perm always on Perm yeah and you've
done this is what I found super
interesting I was watching some of your
videos you've got your colleague who
speaks French you'll like introduce it
black bonjour and then you'll be like
yeah
I love it so you've done UK Market
Germany Market yeah and then again if
I'm wrong past six or so months being
just a French Market yeah yeah
let's go Okay cool so let's start with
this then
what what do you believe are the common
characteristics and traits of a top
performing recruiter in today's market I
was really thinking about this and
didn't want to be too generic with my
answers and I think just to be kind of
clear this is my first job and
the only experience I have of what makes
a good recruiter is people that I might
have interviewed that have joined our
business or that haven't and then the
people around me
I think first and foremost like you've
got to be a good communicator because
the way you articulate things the way
you pitch yourself the way you sell
you know a strategy or a job is
important the way that you like in
recruitment you need to make things
happen you need to over communicate you
need to give feedback sometimes it's not
good so
the way you speak is incredibly
important and it's the reason why people
will work with you time and time again
so I'd say that's number one
I reckon second one is like having an
ability to show up
it's hard
it's tough and you every day just do the
best that you can show up in life show
up for your family few friends in
recruitment you know
um and then I think I didn't want to use
the word resilience so I'm going to use
the word attitude instead but
my concept of resilience is everyone is
inherently resilient life is tough It's
just recruitment will weed out the
people that either are like that or
they're not
I think in recruitment people are you're
dealing with humans who are so
unreliable and they're not data they're
not black and white
you know they can be unpredictable and
you need to have a resilient type of an
attitude in Recruitment and then passion
you know when I started my job like my
director James and Richard I had never
done recruit my life in my life but one
thing I've always had is Passion like
whatever you do in life whether you're a
bin man or bin woman whether you're a
CEO do it with passion and have a love
for it and I think with the right
mindset and the right passion and the
right strategy you will fly in life yeah
I love it I love so let's just go here
because I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on this you started with
communicator and whenever we've spoken
I'd describe you as like a great
communicator
where have you how have you become a
great communicator
I I owe a lot to my family
um my upbringing like my mum and dad are
both very successful in their own right
they've got their own businesses
my mum like she's just an incredible
woman I think everyone loves their mum
but and everyone's like my mum's the
best but my mum is the best she's she's
got her own business she's got a
skincare business she has always showed
me to be respectful speak up for
yourself you have you have you're worthy
to be here
um and speak to anyone whoever they are
with respect and give you know dignity
and
like I like you know one thing that I
I'm not you know I guess is like if we
ever have an issue in the family or
there's an argument I'm like this with
my friends I always talk about it I
overtalk
and I think that's just they've set me
up to how to speak to people and
yeah and communicate I don't know if
that answers the question but obviously
Okay so
clearly then you feel like you've had
like a good like Foundation to be a good
communicator yeah which not everyone has
so then how have you just just curious
just to start here like how have you
got better at it like like for me how
I've I sometimes I'm still I can fall
into it where
I used to be very like speak quick like
I had I had the passion and I was very
much just I was just like that over
excited like salesperson yeah but then
over time I've become just more like
calm collected I pause more I breathe I
I try and really read what the other
person's saying and that's come from
like the Reps and
you know reflecting on how can I be
better so I was just curious like if
you've got that Foundation which is
amazing and sounds like you're really
grateful for
how have you then refined that because
I'm sure you have like when we'll go
into it but one of the things when I
said what do you think you're great at
what your peers would say you said cold
calling like you don't people don't
think that if you're not a good
communicator so how how have you honed
that craft you think
the same way you have you learn from
people like when I started in my job I
had the pleasure of sitting next to
James I know you've met James been on
the podcast sat next to him I used to
get my phone like this and put it next
to him when he was pitching businesses
one of our main clients is idea and work
with them for like 10 years didn't
understand what they were doing at all
it's in the payments world I used to put
my phone and press record and then when
I went home at night I used to listen to
it pause listen you know I think the
most powerful question you can say in
recruitment is why and listen like
people when you Junior you talk too much
got this amazing opportunity stop let me
learn about you let me listen to you and
those responses will be things that you
can use to your in your power and your
ability
so it comes from being surrounded by
great people that are great
communicators like the team that we have
they're amazing like amazing and the way
they speak is great and we're not very
corporate and I've I learned how to how
to do it from there I learned being a
little girl here my dad in the office
you know my dad's in the clothing
industry being on the phone like for
hours dealing pitching that's where I
get it from yeah I love it no so you
find inspiration all over the world
yeah I think what I love about that
story is I I can definitely relate to
that like when I first started in
recruitment I always remember my
um
my uh boss because it was a small team
versus like six or seven of us so I sat
down next to the the founder oh I was
really bad at asking a question and
answering it
like I'd ask you a question and then
sort of just somehow just end up
answering the question because I thought
I knew what you was going to say
so I know a lot of people can relate to
that so what I take from that is like
being willing to like record things
listen to it back practice yourself like
that's something I used to do like
actually practice how I'm going to say
things is a great thing to do yeah just
just to like interject there one thing
I'm good at like when I was about to
speak with you we had our prep call I
was like I need to see if I can like
have a bit of a joke with you I need to
see if I can find some form of a common
ground because once I can't and that
War's broken down and I think we got
Chang and we're talking about like going
for a drink in the culture of
Recruitment and then we got about
looking you know talking about the beer
lucky Saint
um you know and I was like there we go
like we found it you know and
in recruitment if you can find an
ability when it comes to relationship
you call calling commercial leader right
who's had so many of those calls what's
going to make you different find
something on their profile personalize
it get in there and find something that
will make them laugh or it's relatable
you know that's why I'm good at I I can
speak I can pretty much speak to anyone
and if I can make them laugh pretty
quickly I know I know I'm in there you
know yeah
should we get should we get into that
thing because I wanted to ask you about
first year it makes sense too right but
we've ended up here so let's do it right
yeah let's let's get Granada on cold
call then let's do it because I think I
don't know what you think obviously you
correct me if I'm wrong but
the types of people that you recruit are
sales people online yeah gets the go to
Market Commercial function yeah but like
for me my my personal opinion right now
is if you're capable and willing to have
the courage to
Coco build that muscle you have a
competitive Advantage personally because
a lot of people aren't willing to call
on the phone don't have don't have the
courage right yeah so let's go grinding
on this and you can draw on maybe what
why not why don't I'll start with this
what do you think your cold calls
sounded like early on compared to how
they sound like now what are the
different main differences yeah yeah so
my sales approach has changed I think
back in the day I would have you know
um
so there's little things I changed so
instead of me calling you and being like
hi is that Hisham
I'd be like Hisham okay
yeah speaking excellent Hisham good
morning lucky you it's a Monday morning
getting a cold call what a great way to
start the day immediately laugh listen
my name's Sophie Niven I'm a Headhunter
this is a cold call All right but if you
just she's got a few minutes I just want
to get a bit of advice from you people
love helping people
um you know we won't go into the
objection handling I'm going into a
meeting I'm like why'd you answer the
phone then well I thought you might have
been someone for my kids okay can I just
ask you the question and then we'll
we'll do that you know what I mean so
don't sell immediately like if you were
a client and I was learning about you
I'm not going to be like before I even
learn anything about you I'm just going
to talk about myself and pitch my
business no I don't really care what
they want to know is these are the
problems I have what's your solution so
I used to start off with the pitch so
and like can I have 30 seconds of your
time it's Sophie I'm a Headhunter and
then I'll just like no and put the phone
down so you say why so you'd do all that
and then after 30 seconds make them
laugh I'm telling you it's the secret
sauce
um when you say like
also Fridays the best day to do cold
calling you know and at the moment in
France the market I'm on everyone's on
holiday it's in a great mood hopefully
we've got an apple Spritz in the hand
and they're like go on what have you got
to say you know
um but yeah like don't sell too quickly
learn because whatever whatever the
issues you're facing are that'll be the
power that that I have I hear that
you're frustrated like I understand
you've been working with an agency and
it's you've been trying to fill this
position for
eight months that must be really hard
for you from a revenue perspective like
you must be losing a lot of money
whatever they say use it in your power
and flip it back well actually you know
we have a 95 completion rate with all
our candidates whereas the industry
averages 60.
oh and how do you do that oh it's funny
you ask and then go in like that you
know right so let's break this down a
sec okay yeah yeah because that because
no like I can tell how passionate you
are and I absolutely love this so
firstly just interest like interested
like con the typical context of the
people you're calling interested to hear
that are you typically calling people
that you know are hiring are you
typically calling people that you've
found out are hiring for your candidate
Network what's like the typical context
of the people that you're calling out of
Interest
so
go to market is pre-sales sales customer
success marketing and Partnerships so
for example just make it easy
um there's a there's a business that I
want to get into and I'll find the VP of
sales in one of the locations I cover
find his or hers number
and then call right okay so it's not
necessarily your because a lot of people
a lot of recruiters are mainly just
doing BD calls to people that I know
that are hiring but you're just
targeting people that are in your patch
that you know I mean I'm on my phone
here because I want people to be able to
look over this and stop it and just be
like I'm going to do that like I'm gonna
fire some of the things that I do okay
because I really enjoy the business
development side you know once you've
found like after your first year once
you've found your Niche a new area mine
was you know building out sales teams in
France really enjoyed that you you get
an understanding of the market right
whom I tier one business is the
companies that I really want to get into
that heart who are my tier two
businesses that are still great but
maybe they're quite big maybe they have
a big internal team and probably might
not be able to get in there I know a lot
of agencies work on it tier it and then
from all these tier one businesses in
your space mine is like e-commerce and
martech I'll then go through each
company and I'll speak to Canada it's
there how many are open to work if
there's a lot open to work I wonder why
speak to them find out okay that's
information cool
speak to all the commercial leaders
anyone that's relevant and start to
reach out to them and there's so many
things that you can think of
yeah they might be hiring
someone might have left
you might also know that
their Chief revenue office is open to
work speak to him or her find out why
and then do a reverse headhunt and send
someone into him yeah or because there's
such small businesses that we're working
with I've noticed that you don't have a
head of solution engineering ahead of
pre-sales and I can see you growing your
sales team
so when's that going to happen and it's
that detailed approach and they're like
you've actually taken the time to have a
look into the structure of our business
and even see what you think we might
need ask a good recruiter and that's why
I I get clients on yeah I love it okay
okay that really helps in because you've
you've got a targeted approach to one
two two love that so let's just break
this down in because I know there's
things that you want to share and I
think a lot of people could benefit so
I'm a tier one client you might have
spoken to a couple of people in my
organization found out some interesting
information it might be that
you're due to get funding or like
they've raised their targets which means
it likely means they're gonna need more
sales people wherever it may be uh let's
just go through how you how you're
finding yourself uh typically get the
most out of these calls and right now if
I'm a tier one client how are you
opening it up
so I mean we're in a successful place if
I've got a meeting with you first and
foremost because that's the hardest bit
isn't it so well we haven't got me in
there oh right so you found that
information about me I'm in your tier
one list okay so you're the VP of sales
yeah I'm the VP of sales and you might
but you might have done what you've just
did like how do I get you so if you
called me yeah we want to know how you
would go about you know approaching that
call yeah there's so many things so
a bullsey one yeah is there was a
business that I spoke to the other week
where I noticed that a lot of their team
in France was open to work and that's
something that they can't see it's on
LinkedIn on LinkedIn
and I call the VP of sales and also we
work with a lot of businesses they're
incredibly relevant for them I was in a
powerful position here you know I had a
few legs to stand on right called him up
I did my Spiel what was this bill what I
said to you just before like how did you
open up so
um
I didn't I was going to say generic
French name then but I was like I'm not
going to do that you or something it
will be okay
um you know Sophie Niven here from 2B
and we're actually connects on LinkedIn
this is what I'll do we actually
connected on LinkedIn about 15 minutes
ago and you know what I thought I would
do instead of like hiding in behind a
message and saying it's great to connect
I thought I'd give you a call your
number's on your profile and they're
like oh thank you Sophie that's that's
really nice of you I appreciate that
listen I know you know the drill here
like you're a VP of sales you you've LED
commercial teams you know this is a cold
call but
I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you a really
direct question here and I hope you
don't mind okay you know what is it so
we work with X Y and Z okay we've been
doing this for 10 years
um I know that we actually work with one
of your direct competitors we feel this
this amount of roles in this amount of
time so we're already they're like okay
relevant Talent you know what you're
doing you've got social proof here
I I've noticed that you know I don't
know
half of your commercial team is open to
work and I've actually spoken to a few
of them and I know the reasons why
they're looking to leave
and from a revenue perspective that's
not great for you is it
and sometimes they can be like whoa
like who are you to say that right yeah
I respect that I won't always do this
but this was a big company and I wanted
to get into them
you know the defense comes up and like
you know you know my team's very happy
thank you very much and you know it's
like it's okay we can resurrect this
but the average tenure now like the
industry average of candidates are
getting placed is
18 to 24 months and hours is it's to be
precise it's three years and nine months
but it's just shy of four years
so and also our time to hire is quick
in comparison to other people so you're
saving a lot of time you're saving a lot
of Revenue and money being spent
and it also means that the candidates
are being placed into your business
there's a longevity Which is less churn
and less turnover which is a happy
business happy money we're growing we're
flying this is what I can do for you and
he was like all right let's say up then
set up a meeting yeah let's do it
because
excuse my language but I'm not talking
bollocks and that took me weeks of
speaking to a lot of people within that
team to get that information to be
you know risque enough to actually say
it
I wouldn't always suggest doing that
though yeah we're talking no that's a
great example because
what I absolutely love about that I
literally did a post about it this week
like
I'm we're in the world of training
recruiters right so I often see things
that recruiters do don't do and that
example you just gave there's so many
recruiters will not be using their track
record or their company's track records
to like back up what they say
so what I absolutely love about there is
all of the reference references of like
hey we've done this for you we've done
this for competitive we've done this I'm
even going to give you some important
stats you should know about our time to
hire is this and these things so many
people don't do that and they're so I
don't know if you had you had that you
were approached like that from the
beginning uh or it's that's happened
over time but most people uh would
approach that type of call to say you
should be speaking to because I'm a
specialist I only speak to people like
you all the time blah blah I would never
then mention like they're social proof
that you added that's so powerful health
check on an account basically you're
diagnosing the issue here you know and
like it's true if if there was like
quite a few of them spoke to that if
like I've got an offer and I'm gonna
take it like people are genuinely
leaving your business like I can what I
can't do is I can't stop them but what I
can do is I can make sure that if you if
you partner with us as an agency
I've got a pretty high chance of the
talent that we secure in your business
are going to stay and I can I can talk
you through like how we do that
um a lot of that is our approach our
approach and methodology like
were so detailed but like we're we're
not corporate we're fun to work with
like you can probably gauge what the
team's like anyway when we take a
briefing it's like at least an hour long
and it's not just learning the premises
of a role it's like understanding you
like if I was hiring for your business
like I'm just gauging what you're like
as a person culturally what I think you
would enjoy like you know you're a super
sharp guy you obviously you want to have
a sharp team but you want them to be
quite like kind of cool and you know and
then you start assessing someone from
like a personality point of view so we
go through everything make sure that
we're super clear on what they want
and that's how we're able to get like
the best talent and that's why business
is like working with us because we can
get people that other businesses simply
can't like I don't know if I can mention
the company's name so I won't but there
was there's a company that we've just
started recently working with in the
payments industry very well known
business they've got their own in Talent
like in-house team they use an agency on
um three sales roles for nine months and
they didn't place them they've partnered
with us we've got like
loads of people in the process I think
we're almost ready to give offers out
and I think we've had it for like three
weeks four weeks this podcast is proudly
partnered with vincere the all-in-one
recruitment agency software that over 20
000 recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode all right cool so now we went
deep there but like look it let's
let's just get into it like
because as you said you've you really
enjoy the BD element which I'm really
getting which I absolutely love and I
love all this stuff and I know this is
like such a common skill Gap so you just
mentioned it there you've spoken about
cold calling what I highlighted there
for all of you listening is in your cold
calls talk about their problems talk
about them don't just call people up and
talk about yourself couldn't agree more
with that and then also just love how
you weaved in like all of the track
records and the social proof If you said
again if you're listening like you you
need to make sure you're armed with that
talk me through your sales processing
because that's what you're talking about
because I feel like that could be
different and there'll be some insights
in there so talk me through then you did
that cold call
you shared that information you came
across credible
you shared some insights with me I was
like how this Sophie recruiter
is is totally different yeah we book in
the meeting like what's your sales
process do you do Discovery calls and
then you do like talk me through your
typical sales process to take someone to
becoming a client so okay so I've got
you on as as a client you know we've
agreed are we working retained are we
working contingently
um but how do we get to that point
so all right so we've done the cold call
yeah I've done my thing okay so a book
in a meeting and I guess you might call
that Discovery you know call um it might
be myself if I need a bit more weight
because I am still quite you know
relatively Junior in the world of
recruitment I'll bring on my director
for a bit of added Pizzazz you know
um so how long's the meeting
[Music]
up to an hour okay maybe might be 30
minutes it's you do what you can with
the time that you've got so I mean I've
got
six client meetings next week okay so
what I'm going to be doing is
I do loads of research right when was it
founded who's been the recent hires What
markets do they cover what roles have
they recently just hired for
what gaps can I see
who's investing into them who else do I
know that's investing into them is there
any link there okay great go from there
okay and I on my screen two screens I'm
a big advocate of prep like I've got all
my notes I love that okay literally
everything that I need to know I'll even
like I'll look at their profile and if
they were like I don't know they were on
the cricket team or they played rugby or
they did a bit of Lacrosse you know in
France I'll find that and I'll and I'll
be like
start open love is like lovely to meet
you again I know we had that first call
it's actually great to see you on video
I've brought my director James with us
um listen I just want to have a chat
with you I'm not going to do any
hardcore selling on you I actually just
really want to learn a bit more about
you and the business and the plans that
you've got and how we can be of support
and listen if this isn't right
no worries no time wasted great to
connect with you that's a big thing that
I learned which should do that right at
the beginning I even do it on interviews
like the first call I have I'm not like
okay so we're gonna start our interview
now and let's go I'd be like I just want
to have a chat with you like why are you
open to work well the reasons for that
like what would be exciting for you next
when you go into another position what
mission do you want where do you see
yourself what's going to make you like
spring out of bed it's a lot of like
emotive words so so what's the objective
of that meet at that client meeting and
so you've done your prep yeah get them
as a client well them as a client so
here here the problems hear the
struggles that is the main thing when I
got trained with Louise from like the
retained search dig into pain prod it
yeah make sure you know what that is
because that's gonna be solution pitch
right
so there's loads of factors and then
I'll just find out what it is that they
need if I actually can be of help and
then you know maybe I might even pitch
like the solution and get get the deal
closed you know
um okay it usually will work like that
and they'll be like you guys seem great
um do you know what we need a head of
custom success
um brilliant what what stakeholders need
to be on that briefing call get it
closed you know you know what she we
usually typically negotiate terms at
that point yeah like yeah but it happens
organically you know like what's going
to be the next hire I'm working with a
business called Cobra French series a
business
um work with Anton the co-founder and
that's literally how I did it with him
he's like you guys seem great so on this
chord because I'm curious so like on
that call then like you said you frame
it up the agenda is Hey look
Sophie what I'm really Keen to do here
is understand a lot more about you yeah
I've done some prep I've got some
assumptions but I'm really Keen to you
know hear it from you and then look if
it makes sense to I can talk a bit about
how we've maybe help companies like
yours but at the very least hopefully
you know I can be of service here in
some way with connected whatever
whatever that sounds like but that's how
you frame it up and then like you said
I'm assuming that during that meeting
you're prodding you're finding out what
problems they've run into all of that
and then depending on what you find out
you're then going to go well look from
what you've shared to me today this is
why I think I should talk to you about
how I might be able to help yeah stories
like
storytelling is huge I think in sales
um you know I might be like if you can
relate anything to a similar situation
to someone else
so I could be speaking to a therapist
and you know they're like I understand I
once actually had a similar situation
you know this this and this happened and
this is how it made me feel but this is
what I did to make it better do the same
in sales you know it must be really hard
for you've worked with several agencies
you've been burnt you know the quality
has been poor you spent a lot of money
you've done retained you know why do you
want to do why would you want to pay
retained with me you know to someone
that you don't even know you know what
it's like but you know for example like
we worked with a business called X they
were reluctant to work with us they'd
been burnt before
it cost them x amount of Revenue you
know that they got lost
um but what we did is we did this this
and this
and we actually saved them this amount
of money and instead of them like that
business of the payments business that
took them nine months no hires and we've
we've boxed off in a month
so that's a great way to close like if
if Junior recruiters can get into this
storytelling mindset that is powerful so
then how and then how do you typically
like close out those meetings then so
you hit them with a store and then like
so yeah then how do you typically close
those out then
uh
I think my my Approach is probably um
I'm quite like organic with it all so if
they're just
about how do you feel about it like you
know do you think this could be a good
partnership and and you get the gist and
the main object is is like I need to
have a think about it if someone needs
to think about something you've not
given them enough information quite
frankly like if you if someone says to
me like I need to have a think about it
either I've not done a good enough job
explaining like what we do as a business
you know or maybe you do need to speak
to someone but I just will be like
excellent I'm going to send you our you
know terms and conditions let me know if
you've got any questions let me know if
there's anything unhappy about that's
when the objectives come because they're
like okay how much do you charge 25 the
first year's salary
so I'm happy with that some aren't if
they try and negotiate and Whittle me
down I've got this
um I've got this saying I remember this
CEO was like it's pretty ridiculous that
you charge 25 the first year salary and
I was like would you go and can I ask
you a question like would you go into
the Gucci store and ask for a discount
and he's like well no I of course not I
was like why would it be any different
with me like
what we have an impressive track record
like we can we we do this incredibly
well
you know if if you want Gucci then if
you want Gucci but like if you if you uh
and you are say give me two weeks if
you're not happy with the way that I'm
working and you're not satisfied you
don't need to work with me and if
anything it's time wasted on my side not
yours
and I've never lost a client like from
that from that yeah so that is a way
I'll close if they're really reluctant
give me two weeks let me show you what
I'm about and they you know they like it
yeah
in terms you were saying um
in terms of the the objection there so
if because that is a quite a typical one
look we've gone through a lot of Sophie
I'm you know I need to think about this
how do you you know weed out the people
that are just sort of following you off
out of Interest then because I've
definitely got my approach to that my
favorite is like how do I know that
you're any good
you know and someone says that to you
yeah I'm like do you know what how do
you you know it's you know if I if a VP
of sales says that to me I usually say
the same reason that the person that
hired you
is like you know what I mean because
like a VP of sales what do they do they
do a pitch they present their trap
record they present their figures
great this on paper they look great you
never know what they like until they
actually start the job so it's the same
way around I could be all talk but until
we work together that's when you really
see what we're about
um and we just don't lose clients so
it's more it's more just like a trust
like I think the proof is in the pudding
if you're starting off in recruitment
like I was I had literally no experience
whatsoever lean on your portfolio lean
on the the numbers that you have like
you know our candidates stay with like
we've got the facts and I present that
and
I I don't know if this is like gray but
I I also have no problem I think there's
a question that you asked me like about
my top biller kind of strategy and one
thing is being disciplined with the
companies that you work with you when
you're a junior you like say yes to
everything when businesses aren't that
great
and I've stopped doing that if you
really don't like our approach and
you're not going to trust me then I
don't think this is going to be a good
partnership
but the clients that I won in year one I
still work with them now that's that's
how I got my top built like 200 of my
target was with the first ever company
that I ever signed
so you've got better at walking away
yeah like Craig David says you've got to
walk away not working on jobs or
like not fillable jobs or people that
aren't willing to give you time these
things yeah that that is so important
and I think
Junior recruiters have this block when
it comes to senior work they don't feel
like confident enough they don't feel
worthy enough to work on it but if you
actually think about it senior people
this is what I like to they're the best
to work with bigger fees predictable
Revenue less likely to flake out of
processes when you place them guess who
they're going to call to hire their team
you
um and also like they're just great to
work with anyway like I I will look
through all my top companies see what
open to work senior leaders there are
work with them nurture them
build out a list to prospect into
companies that they want to go into and
they what they start to see is like the
level of service that you offer and
they're like You're great and if you
don't play some a business that you know
but you place them and they go somewhere
else they're going to call you that's
happened to me so many times because the
experience yeah I've just joined as
Chief Revenue officer love the way that
you handled me and everything so let's
have a chat great you know bigger fees
as well we're talking like 20K plus
that's how I've been able to achieve
like the success that I've had is moving
away from Junior low you know like tier
two positions just because you're trying
to squeeze them in
to higher value positions
I love that
you love it then yeah I love how
passionate you are I I do like I I just
love it I know I work in a really great
business and I'm very lucky but you know
I am a very passionate girl anyway yeah
no I love it just the way I am so
curious then because I'm sure again
because you've
you've re like you've really highlighted
here how you're just really committed to
like you are a great service and you
you've got you can just tell how
confident you are in your uh service and
what you bring to the table
so I I just want to ask like
did you did you have that at the
beginning confidence
like that just that com the way that
you're talking about your service and
why I should partner with you I can see
that how that comes across and I think
as you're you know earning your stripes
it's quite difficult to have
do you mean like the way that I come
across or so like in your first six
months
how like was you still very much
pitching for business the way that you
came across them like what was you
leaning on because you you've got a lot
more evidence now to go I'm I'm
good at what I do I mean you see me in
my third year you know like
I've always I've always been a bit like
this but my first year I think like I
was telling you that it was literally
like James and Rick the co-founders Luke
Woods who's the longest standing
employee great guy shout out to Luke
um we had like one of the guy who ended
up traveling to like Australia and we
still keep in contact with him then it
was me first female hire now the great
thing about joining a startup like that
is you get thrown into the deep end in
the best way possible yeah I'm sat next
to James and he's like okay he's like
from the get-go we're not a haze we
don't have a full training thing but I'm
gonna teach you how to be the best and
I'm gonna give you all the knowledge
that I can poor man I used to ask him a
million questions you know and
like any advice to people sawing in
recruitment is ask questions learn
listen like all the people now that have
started like we've got Juliet who's
doing incredibly well like
almost she's going to be billing more
than I did in my first year she's sick
she constantly like can I just have 15
minutes with you and just get some time
in with you you know like be proactive
seek help so what sort of things are you
asking you I thought was she asking me
um
how to give negative feedback
how to manage my time it can be
overwhelming I just feel like I've got
loads on and I've got a few techniques
like people think I'm crazy but I listen
to Brown noise
listen to Brown noise like what babies
listen to Brown noise you've got like
white noise there's different
frequencies here there's different
frequency Brown noise what's brown noise
Brown is like
like a low okay frequency and I listen
to that and I'd be like guys I'm gonna
just plug in I need to do like two hours
of searching unless it's urgent you know
what I mean
um and then there's like the Pomodoro I
think hopefully it's happening yeah yeah
about a minute it's 25 minutes yeah like
I'm all about balance in life I have
never been an advocate I don't think
it's cool to like stay late you know
like or push yourself to burn out I'm
very good at balancing it work optimally
work efficiently so work on a task so
anyway just I guess to answer your
question like I just got thrown into it
very quickly
um and with a lot of support I remember
in my first week I was speaking to
candidates I was speaking to my first VP
of sales and I was like James I'm
speaking to people themselves and he was
like just another person just maybe
instead of asking like how can you open
be like what do you want your next
mission to be but speak to them how you
speak to anyone else and now speak to
Chief for every officer I'm like it's
fine whatever people are people so yeah
that's probably how I built up no yeah I
guess and then and just find a point on
that just quickly did they did James and
the guys equip you with like the data
the case studies early on yeah
so James James and Rick got adien which
is a huge payment processing business
um then you leverage that yeah yeah so
if if all I did was looked at
competitors of
Adian or or payment businesses within
that space you've got a real story to
talk to them about it's all you need one
one business you've had a good
partnership with you've done well it
will no that I just think that's the
inside that's that's also where that
confidence can come from right by being
in a supportive environment all these
things
so you're talking about give us give us
more the time management stuff then if
you have people coming up to say no I'm
really struggling prioritizing you just
said Brown noise you mentioned two hours
you mentioned Pomodoro Technique how how
are you typically setting up your day
for efficiency well great Eva so I've
got let me just get that note on here
I've got my this is your day plan I've
got like a bit of a BD plan that I do
need to use a daily activity it's like
brushing your teeth you need to be
consistent on it every day
and if you're not brushing to you twice
a week why twice a week twice a day what
are you doing
I love that BD is like cleaning your
teeth
love that plenty so if you think of a
week
you've got you've got your candidate
side you've got your client side okay
every day this is like once you set up
and you know what company is going
through every day I do LinkedIn
searching from the companies I want to
get into who is open to work who has
just joined in mail them make sure it's
personalized it's better to spend and
now we're sending 20 personalized
messages than it is to just do a mass in
meld and hope that it sticks
my there's a little plug here my inmail
rate so the average is 26 mine's 46
percent let's go
right so I'll do LinkedIn searching
check who's open to work if you just
spend one day this is like a little tip
I've got if you just spent one day
going through all the senior leaders
that were open to work interviewing them
and then
sending a similar profile into their
hiring manager or their boss you will
make like money that is one tax that you
can do so LinkedIn searching every day
um network with them always work with
senior candidates that are open to work
um information find out why people are
leaving why they've joined that's going
to be stuff that you use when you're
actually trying to pitch to the company
personalized content or like that is the
thing I'm really passionate about like
some of the the writing that we've got
is incredible we often get
like this is the best message I've ever
received from a recruiter
I can't stress how important that is
you've got people who want an example
mate they want an example people are
going to want an example can you think
of a lot like a like let's be honest
though look I'm big into this as well
like I did a PO I did a post last week
or this week so I don't know who's our
SDR like seven weeks into the journey
like we've invested I've tried to invest
a lot in like our Playbook and we're
here to solve problems all that stuff
right and she's had responses uh from
two three people already saying this is
that was the best sales call I've ever
had that was the best message I've ever
had yeah good for you that's great yeah
I think that's Mega but people want
examples right but the reason why I'm
saying that was
unless you disagree the personalization
bit in the bit you change is normally
you might experiment with the subject
line but then it's like the beginning
bit and then the other bit is like
normally templated or like there's
there's a core element to it I don't
know what yours is but typically it's
the beginning bit that you're going to
put some work into
so there's a business that I want to get
into I'm not going to share the name
because it's yeah
um but they've just you'll probably be
able to find it if I actually say this
book I'm all about giving advice so it's
fine they're going to become like Forbes
next like you know billion dollar tech
company okay so I I messaged the founder
who I'm connected to and I was like am I
speaking to like Forbes next one billion
dollar like tech company nice question
mark like incredible news so happy for
you so I try and find something that's
cheeky like wanna we've got a one of the
Consultants called Sam Goodall He is
unbelievable at content and like he'll
do things like instead of doing private
confidential he'll do confidential and
private comma sort of you know just make
it and by the way like our our audience
are you know funky startups and
scale-ups who you know don't like the
corporate jargon I was reading the other
day that
um this like put this like recruit um
candidate did a screenshot of all the
emails I had of recruiters and every
single one started with hi name hope
you're well if you saw that don't do
that so yeah okay one thing I might say
is like you Superstar
um you know Superstar candidate me
French recruiter like with a sick face
um
excellent I'm glad that we've been
introduced right why am I actually
contacting you well I can you know it's
your experience at X business that looks
really interesting but quite frankly I
don't know if you are a good fit but you
look great
this is I also am very transparent about
the business I'm representing the salary
that they're offering yeah yeah be open
um I'd love to have a chat with you and
they're like best in mail ever you've
taken the time yeah I appreciate you
sharing that sorry I'll call either stop
I might have to edit that out you know I
don't know
you'll be fine BD plan what else you've
got going on there then yeah what else
is there to share in the BD plan
um what else have I got so oh yeah
WhatsApp multi-channel there's a company
that is
a top prospect for me that I've been
trying to get into for ages and I found
I don't need to know I won't I was like
don't don't say anything and I just was
ballsy enough to message the VP of
southern Europe on WhatsApp found his
number and I was like hi name Sophie
Niven here from 2B Talent Solutions
principal Headhunter hope you don't mind
the direct approach here over WhatsApp
but I understand that you get absolutely
bombarded by recruiters I'm trying to
cut through the noise
this is the businesses that we work for
um I lead the French region you've just
started let's talk and he was like you
are the first person that has ever
reached out to me on Whatsapp let's have
a call because if you can get me I know
that you can get people yeah let's go
you should see my business WhatsApp it's
outrageous yeah I do everything on
WhatsApp everything that is the secret
sauce to to getting people yeah love it
what else do you do
anything else to to share that you feel
has helped you like mentally then
oh mentally well I guess it ties into my
passion for Olympic like lifting if
that's what you wanted to speak about do
you want to join me to go into like how
do I keep a positive mindset yeah I
think that because yeah I think that'd
be helpful for people because I I do
feel like you come yeah like people were
getting that from you which is amazing
but I don't know how you feel but some I
feel like sometimes people can feel like
oh I just don't have that
listen to this a lot I just don't have
what Sophie has
right okay so
it's a hard question to answer what's
helped you develop that positive mental
attitude and then we can go into like
when you've maybe thought about quitting
or you've had a major setback and
what helped you in this moments
so you I am just very positive I've been
like this all my life you know I've gone
through some tough bits like we all have
and
I just don't quit like you can literally
bash me to the ground to a pulp maybe I
might quit I Won't Give Up it might be a
little bit of a hindrance to me because
I don't know when to give in but I I've
got a point to prove you know it's hard
being a ginger girl you know growing up
you know what I mean like I'm tough my
mum's tough it's the way I've been
brought up so there's that like it's
just the way I am but
you know if you if you like my God the
first year I was in a constant state of
being overwhelmed constantly and like
being out of my depth and you know like
imposter syndrome was real you know I I
can't be doing this I can't be pitching
a retainer trying to get
a lot of money from a business like what
am I doing but you've you've got to
outside of work you've got to work on
yourself you've got to understand your
value you know I was nervous for this
today I've got two two in a bit years of
experience like what am I doing here but
you know I love what you do I'm excited
by it and I know you know the deal with
Recruitment and
looking great to be on here you know
what I mean so it's just my mindset but
training has been like the best thing
for me ever it's the one thing in my
life
um exercise that I've kept consistent
that has pulled me through
Dark Times great times whatever is is
why
did it help with that though
well I don't know why it helps with that
I'm sure there's scientific reasons for
it or just like your experience like
I've got my own thoughts on that like
it's just like how it why why you
believe it helps you yeah with that
everyone everyone has advice everyone
needs somewhere that they can relieve
stress some people it's alcohol some
people it's drugs some people it's
whatever for me it's exercise like I do
Olympic lifting and it's very intense
hardcore heavy lifting and it suits my
personality well like the job I do you
know you're like let's go let's go
buzzing all day like there's no chill
day in recruitment
when I get home and I decompress I
decompress in the gym you know I
physically can't think of anything else
because it's you know I use my brain a
lot when I do my Limpet lifting it to be
present yeah you've got to be present
you know and I'm very good at I'm lucky
I'm very good at switching off like I
can get home and be like I'll leave that
because I guess like my brother's a
doctor right and I've had the like the
pleasure of living with him quite
recently and like he's got like people's
lives in his hands like real life and
death serious and then the day like
it's I can leave it and I will go back
to it in the morning and it will be okay
like what's the worst that's gonna
happen what is the worst that's gonna
happen so I don't know if that helps but
if she's good to hear how other people
do of it right because and it's also
good to hear that even though you're all
coming across confident these things
that definitely in your first year you
you had that self-dialogue
yeah well like I still feel like that
now it never goes like
you feel like a bit of a fraud like I
didn't go to university
um my whole family did I went off and
lived in Australia for four years and
like start moving social media business
there and
you know I've always been a little bit
of a black sheep like in my family and
you either you either use that to your
advantage or you let it consume you and
I was just like it actually makes me
different you know
it's it's okay to feel overwhelmed
sometimes like say to people like in the
office
stop take a minute go outside take a few
deep breaths you've got this you've got
it let's go
yeah it's okay I'm here we're here to
support you you've got it
your workplace is so important God yeah
no no for sure um look you you tell me
then to round this out I know we went
ground on the BD stuff which we wanted
to do right we're never always gonna be
able to cover everything but I think
there's there's so many helpful things
there you went into a lot of granular
things so let me just pass this over to
you then before we finish like you tell
me your experience of being the first
female in a business
and also probably learning and
understanding that you're also in an
industry that is often dominated by men
like you tell me your experience I want
to make sure I answer this well I've got
like a little portion here all right
talk to me then um I said you didn't I
like I'm very my thing is like I don't
want to be like oh Sophie is a female
which means she must have had challenges
and it must have but like this is like
to you like you tell me your experience
which could help other other people
listening to this
when you know when you are choosing a
recruitment business it's you know the
industry is
a lot of men right you know when you
when you join somewhere you will get a
feel I did 14 interviews before I chose
to be I knew I wanted you know as soon
as you step into that door am I going to
be respected am I going to be valued
do my values align with them your
workplace is important not everyone is
going to be your Champion but you need
to be around people that are supportive
like
you know James and Rick like they've
they've always pushed me to do things
like neighbors you've got it like go and
do it they're my like my hype men who
you surround yourself by in life and in
the workplace incredibly important if
you have people that are like oh you
know shouldn't really be doing that or
you know can I speak to someone else
with a bit more Authority it's not the
right place to be in so there's that and
I think women
suffer everyone suffers but women suffer
with imposter syndrome I shouldn't be
here I'm not experienced enough I'm not
confident enough I don't know what I'm
doing
my advice if you feel like that is
people feel like that because they feel
like they they're not
they don't have the information or the
knowledge so I felt like that for a long
time but it was actually because I
didn't really know how to pitch the
business very well or
I didn't feel like I knew a particular
sector so what did I do I went and
learned it yeah don't you confuse it
with a skill Gap yeah yeah you like
so if I was exceptionally nervous for
this it means I've either not prepared
well
or I don't actually know how to do my
job but I would have prepared well and
I'm good at my job yeah so I'm I deserve
to be here you deserve to be here like
it's a wonderful thing so there's that
um
and I think and just to kind of as my
last Point here is the industry that I
work with I speak to like King brilliant
women like you know senior women you
know investors
um leaders that have got big teams big p
l responsibilities like it's happening
there is a big shift in this world like
we've got no time to be quiet as women
speak up say what you want to say you
know I've always I've always had no
issue like if if somebody interrupts me
I will say something
um if someone speaks over me I will say
something have confidence know your
worth
you know and be around people that um
that are Advocates of that and if
they're not it's time to move and it's
it's that's you know just as a last last
finisher I'm I'm I'm passionate to
please God if I have children I'm
passionate to show my the Next
Generation like you can do whatever you
want to do and it's happening now so
come on you know
yeah love it so it's been absolute
pleasure I love pleasure energy it's
infectious uh keep being you thank you
so much for having me I've honestly
thoroughly enjoyed it